retinoids are the gold
standard skincare ingredients
they are the next essential product right
after sunscreen because they can help you
with so many skin issues and there's
scientific evidence to back them up
but it's really tricky to work
out which one you should use and
it really doesn't help that there's
so much incorrect info out there but
if you find the right one it can make
such a huge difference to your skin
my PhD is in medicinal chemistry and I'm
a qualified cosmetic chemist so seeing all
these myths and traps that people fall for when
it comes to retinoids that physically hurts me
so in this video I'm going to break down drug
versus cosmetic retinoids their pros and cons
why drugs are a bit overrated
cosmetics are really underrated
and compounded retinoids are super overrated
which one you should use and I'm going to
bust a whole bunch of myths along the way
if you don't already know retinoids are
skincare ingredients that work like vitamin A
they work by attaching to
retinoid receptors in your skin
basically retinoids are like keys that
fit into locks which are the receptors
and when that happens they will trigger an effect
or rather they trigger a whole bunch of effects
which is why retinoids are so great in skincare
but also why they burn your freaking
face off but we will get to that in a bit
if you're looking into skincare you probably have
some sort of goal in mind and retinoids
will probably help you towards that goal
if you have acne then retinoids can stop pores
from clogging up and turning into pimples
if you want to even out pigment then retinoids
can help normalize that pigment production process
if you want less wrinkles smoothed out
scars and pores then retinoids will increase
collagen that's a protein that's inside your
dermis that makes it like a thicker mattress
but not all retinoids work the
same and not all products with
the same retinoid will work the same either
some retinoids are drugs and for these
you will generally need a script but
adapalene is available over the counter sometimes
cosmetic retinoids like retinol
are in regular skincare products
my PhD was mostly medicinal chemistry
and I studied pharmacology in undergrad
so when I first started getting
into skincare it just seemed like
why would anyone use cosmetics
when you could just use the drugs
lots of doctors and scientists think this way and
that's because most scientists and
doctors don't get taught much about
cosmetics and honestly not that much about
drugs either or at least the finer details
but there are some really
well-known benefits of drugs
first off drug ingredients have demonstrated
efficacy and that means they've gone through
an approval process it is a bit
like hazing except for molecules
there are studies done using these
on lots of people and then regulatory
agencies with lots of experts checked through all
that data and decided there was enough
evidence to say that these are effective
so when a tube of adapalene says
it'll treat acne then it's going
to do that or at least the chance of
it doing that is going to be higher
there are other factors that
can affect whether or not it
will work for you specifically but
the chances are as good as it gets
there's also a lot more independent research
on drugs from lots of different research
groups and less on cosmetics for… reasons
check out my previous video for that
but the conclusion is it doesn't mean
that cosmetic retinoids don't work we just
have to do a lot more educated guesswork and
that's going to be in my next retinoid video
plus I mean they gatekeep
the stuff it's so powerful
they make you jump through hoops to get it
it just gives off a lot more like power vibes
a less obvious but really really
important upside is that the final
formula of a drug is also tested for effectiveness
now a lot of you are probably thinking about
the percentage and you're correct but if you
watched some of my other videos before you'll
know it goes a lot further than just that
you can't just dump 0.05% tretinoin into some
random moisturizer and expect
it to work as well as this guy
basically if you have a good
drug base it needs to convince
that active ingredient to leave the
product that you've just applied on
your skin go into your skin and go deep
enough to reach the retinoid receptors
some ingredients will go into skin more
easily because of their properties so they
might be a bit smaller or they might have
just the right balance of oil and water
solubility but other ingredients need
a bit more convincing from that formula
the cool thing about drugs is that
this formula here is pretty much
the same one that worked in the scientific studies
and I think all this control and regulation over
drug formulas is where one of the
biggest myths in skincare comes from
I see this from influencers and dermatologists
and scientists and pharmacists all the time
it's the idea that percentage is
everything that matters about skincare
a lot of people fall into this trap
and it's especially people who are
used to giving out actual medications like
doctors and pharmacists and that's because
for drugs you can usually assume that if
the percentage of the active ingredient
is the same then the generic is going to
work the same as the brand name product
but the only reason you can assume this is
actually because of this regulation in the
background regulators make brands demonstrate
that their generic drug formula doesn't just
have the same percentage of active but
that it actually works the same on skin
this is something called bioequivalence
and there's a whole bunch of studies that
generic drug makers need to run to show that their
product is bioequivalent equivalent
on the skin to the brand name one
if it doesn't work the same and they
still want to sell it then they have
to go through a whole separate much
more complex drug approval process
so when it comes to drugs all this
hard work is done by regulators and
manufacturers in the background so
you usually just need to check that
you've got the same active ingredient
the same percentage and the same form
but all of this regulatory gatekeeping just
doesn't really happen with cosmetic skincare
you might have a badly formulated 1%
retinol that just like sits on top of
your skin and then you might have a really
well formulated 0.2% retinol that actually
gets more of that retinol down through your
skin into the receptors but if you're only
looking at the percentage then you would
end up picking the less effective product
there's also better stability regulation for drugs
drugs and cosmetics are both usually tested
for standard stability unless there
something that's gone really wrong
so this is stuff like is it
going lumpy or moldy too quickly
but for drug retinoids the manufacturers
actually need to make sure the active
ingredient lasts in their specific
formula and in that specific packaging
so if you follow the storage directions on
the packaging and you should always read
them and I totally didn't read them for
the first time when I was preparing for
this video it should stay pretty close
to 0.05 or 0.1% until the expiry date
but most of the time this doesn't happen
for cosmetics which is a problem because
retinoids are pretty unstable
they just fall apart all the time
now some cosmetic brands do put in extra effort to
make sure that their retinoid products are stable
and I will talk about those in my next cosmetic
retinoid video but the thing is they don't have to
it's perfectly legal for a brand to
just dump 1% retinol into a random
cream and then just sell that and
it might be completely decomposed
by the time it gets to you and it's
both legal and actually pretty common
there's this research group that tested
a whole bunch of retinoid products and
a lot of the retinoids in these were
half gone 6 months after opening them
and product quality quality in general
is just better for drug products there's
just more of a guarantee that they
contain what they say they contain
now this is also legally required for cosmetics
they should also have an accurate ingredients
list but things slip through the cracks
and they slip through less for drugs
there's more controls over
how drugs are manufactured
drug labs have to be certified
for good manufacturing practice
I know that kind of sounds like
I'm talking about like backyard
drug labs but I'm not I'm talking
about actual drug manufacturers
so there are a whole bunch of examples
of mix-ups that's happened with cosmetics
for example the inkey list they
got into trouble for having 3.4%
salicylic acid in their 2% cleanser which
is higher than the legal limit in the EU
now this might seem like it's some sort of bargain
because you're getting more of your active but I
don't think it was actually intentional because
it was like above the legal limit it was illegal
so it does kind of make you wonder if they're
messing that up what else are they messing up
the FDA did a study in 2009 and they
tested the retinoids in 29 cosmetics and
1/5th of them had the wrong retinoid
or they had the wrong concentration
the research group from earlier they also tested
a whole bunch of freshly opened retinoid products
and almost all of the ones that had a
percentage on the label had a different
percentage of retinoid inside and a bunch of
them also just had the wrong retinoid inside
and again this does happen with drug products too
but there are just a lot more safeguards in place
so all of this just makes it sound like
drug retinoids are amazing and they are
to an extent but there also some downsides that
aren't really as obvious until you've been deep
in both the drug and the cosmetic worlds and
you've thought about this for way way too long
the biggest pro in my opinion is that there is
just so much more flexibility when it comes to
cosmetic formulas which is like the flip
side of all this strict drug regulation
once a drug formula gets approved
the brand can't really change it
very much without going through a new
super expensive drug approval process
and again it isn't just about
percentage or even what other
moisturizing actives they have inside
the formula so for example Altreno is
0.05% tretinoin inside a lotion base and
that base also has sodium hyaluronate
I don't know why that word is so hard to say
collagen and glycerin and that ends up
being less irritating the manufacturer
was already making 0.05% tretinoin in a gel
base with the same moisturizing ingredients
so to get this new lotion base
approved they had to do two 12
week clinical trials that had over 1,600 people
that is is a lot of money
according to the average in
this study this would have been tens of millions
also yes that is hyaluronic acid in the formula
can we please stop fearmongering
about how bad it is in skincare
yes it can make some ingredients penetrate
more because it is hydrating and that can
lead to irritation but there is also
evidence that some sizes will work as
an anti-aging active we don't give other
anti-aging actives a hard time for being
irritating sometimes and drug companies
are intentionally putting it in formulas
that they're betting millions of
dollars on to be less irritating
anyway that is a rant for a different video
as you've probably worked out the big reason
we want flexibility in formulas is irritation
it is a huge issue it's the main
reason people drop out of clinical
trials for retinoids and why
people just stop using them
there are lots of hacks for making
them less irritating I did a video
on this a while back but almost everyone
who uses the stronger retinoids will end
up applying a bit too much at some point
and you end up like a red itchy peeling
mess and it always happens right when
you don't want to have that happening
like today when I was putting on makeup
and there's a whole bunch of evidence that you
can change the irritation by changing the formula
a lot of these newer drug retinoid formulations
have these sorts of features but they are in
tons of cosmetic products but most of the time
when you have a drug formula it is super basic
and there's another bonus in this whole vein
of irritation and messing up your application
anecdotally there is just a lot more leeway if
you apply too much of a cosmetic retinoid you
you aren't just slapped with regret with all this
like peeling and irritation and redness like you
are for drug retinoids and this might actually be
because of how cosmetic retinoids convert in skin
most of them need to turn into tretinoin to work
properly and a lot of people see this purely as a
downside it means that they do tend to be weaker
and less likely to work but it might actually
help them be essentially self-limiting
and time release versions of tretionin
these are the steps for most cosmetic retinoids
turning into tretinoin these first two steps are
reversible so this might look familiar if you know
a bit about equilibrium and buffers in chemistry
in theory if you apply too much of any of
these top ones it can kind of overflow and
turn into the other things and not tretinoin
they might just turn into tretinoin a bit later
but if you apply too much tretinoin there's
no pathway that goes back to the less potent
versions because that is not a reversible
process so there are just less systems in
place for buffering any excess overflow
and it ends up being a lot less forgiving
there's also availability most of
the time it's just a lot easier to
get cosmetic products for most
of these drug retinoid you need
to go to a doctor and have them
decide if you should get a script
there's also a really limited number
of drug formulas in some countries
you can't get all of the retinoids easily like
tazarotene is really hard to get in Australia
drug products also get discontinued all
the time without having a good replacement
and it's a lot easier to buy cosmetic
products from legit retailers overseas
so drug versus cosmetic retinoid
which one should you go for
I'm going to go through some of the very
general things you might want to think about
obviously I am a chemist not a medical doctor
and I don't know the specifics of your situation
if you're not sure you should really book
a consult with a cosmetic dermatologist
first off strength and tolerance drug retinoids
are generally stronger and most of them aren't
really formulated to reduce irritation so
you do need to use them really carefully at
the start and even then most people are
going to end up having some irritation
so think about can your skin handle retinoids
this isn't the same for other irritating
ingredients so for example my skin is really
good at tolerating chemical peels so I thought
I would be fine just slapping on retinol I was
not fine my skin just kind of leapt off my face
so if you haven't used retinoids before
cosmetic ones are probably a better
starting point there are also some genetics
involved in retinoid irritation so if your
relatives have used them before
that might give you an indication
some studies have also found that
East Asian skin is less tolerant
if your skin is sensitive in general a big part of
retinoid irritation is to
do with barrier disruption
so if your barrier isn't really happy
to begin with then you probably want to
take it slow maybe start with a cosmetic retinoid
availability and price this depends on
where you are so if you have generic
drug retinoids that can end up cheaper
but that might also depend on pack size
obviously you also need to factor in the cost
of the doctor's appointment if you're going for
the prescription ones and which doctors can
actually prescribe retinoids in your region
you can buy prescription retinoids
from overseas pharmacies and some of
them don't really check if you have a script
but I am really not a big fan of this option
a lot of the time you don't end up really covered
by either country's regulations so
a lot of those advantages of drug
retinoids are gone like guaranteed formula
efficacy stability and that quality control
all right we need to talk about compounded
drug retinoids and this is where you have a
specially trained pharmacist they mix
up a custom formulation from a doctor
so for example something like this with
tretinoin azelaic acid and niacinamide
it's what a lot of those telederm
custom skincare companies are doing
like apostrophe curology hers dermatica
and this isn't like a criticism of
any of them specifically but it's just a
limitation of this whole system in general
it might kind of seem like you're getting the best
of both worlds you're getting drug and cosmetic
you're getting a custom formula which has those
drug actives you want at effective concentrations
but if you think about all of these
pros and cons that we've just been
through you actually lose a lot of the
advantages of both drugs and cosmetics
on the upside you do get the more effective
drug retinoid as the active but because it's
a custom formula the formula efficacy
and stability aren't being tested
compounding pharmacists are going
to look for obvious clashes and
then mix the ingredients into some
sort of generic base but that is it
so the efficacy and stability is almost definitely
going to end up worse than an off-the-shelf drug
retinoid maybe even some cosmetic skincare
products that have been properly tested
the formula flexibility also isn't that great
you do get to combine actives but the compounding
pharmacy might not necessarily have a huge range
and it will depend on what your doctor gives you
you usually also don't get much
choice for the base it's a base
that's been optimized to work well
for a bunch of different actives
it's not really optimized to be for
tretinoin or necessarily nice to use
there are some telederm companies that have
nicer bases they use but it's
still not really a guarantee
in theory they could be optimizing their
formulas and making them deliver better
and be more stable because they do tend
to prescribe a whole bunch of formulas
that are really similar but as far as I can
tell none of them are actually doing that
all of them seem to have some reviews saying that
their brand new product has like scratchy crystals
in it and that is a pretty basic stability
issue that shouldn't be there for cosmetics
their expiry dates are usually the
default compounding 3 to 4 months
versus 6 to 12 months for an off-the-shelf drug
retinoid also 6 to 12 months or even
longer for the good cosmetic retinoids
so I actually think a better option for
most people would just be layering and
off-the-shelf drug with a cosmetic skincare
product that has the other actives you want
it's a lot less convenient for application you
do have to squeeze out two products instead of
one but you can get good stability
for the separate products and there
is efficacy testing and stability testing for
the drug and maybe also the cosmetic product
the efficacy might drop a bit if you mix them
but it is still better than no testing and
you can wait a bit in between layers to
try to give it the best chance possible
but it does really depend on your
situation for some people it might
end up better because you do get
that doctor's appointment wrapped
up in there but I think just the
formula part is just super overrated
so that is drug versus cosmetic retinoids
we did it Joe
remember you don't have to choose
just one or the other I personally
will use both depending on how my skin is feeling
now before you start slapping a retinoid
on your face you'll want to know how you're
meant to introduce them without your
skin falling off I have a video on that
and my ebook tells you how to
get a skincare routine going
next I'll be talking about all the different drug
retinoids then I'll go into
all the cosmetic retinoids
in the meantime you can check out my deep dive
on vitamin C or just my skincare science playlist
special shoutout to Sam one of my ex-students
who is a pharmacist and pharmacy instructor
for helping me out on the compounding
stuff and Ruby for giving me feedback
you can check out the written version of this on
my website which has a lot
more info and references